hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
i'll just juggle you i'm just checking
in on you seeing how your week is going
are you sitting on pins and needles
oh my god who's gonna win
are we sticking with the orange [ __ ]
oh we going with forgetful freddy ah
geez what an absolute
absolute [ __ ] show uh donald trump just
churning out the comedy
like you just can't believe stop
counting the votes keep counting the
votes
they should close the polls p-o-l-e-s
[Music]
he might be an idiot but he's our idiot
right and then on the other side
is the anybody but trump people
uh this guy is showing like signs of um
i well he the [ __ ] trump is that it's
unbelie
it is so [ __ ] ridiculous i'm really
sticking to what i said
a couple of months back i don't think
the democrat
i think this country is so [ __ ] right
now
you know we all know oh look our money's
a ponzi scheme okay we've we're having a
great time we're all believing in it and
all that [ __ ] but we're in the middle of
a pandemic they keep pumping more money
i just think it's teetering because what
i i've maintained
this entire election was all the
democrats needed was a 45 year old guy
with a full head of hair
and they had it who could complete a
[ __ ] sentence instead they find a guy
even older than [ __ ] trump
and now we got a photo finisher
everybody knows if you want to beat the
old guy
you you you're wheeling something
[ __ ] pretty to look at
the democrats wouldn't do it oh he's got
a facelift i think
he only looks like he's 79.
i would never guess he's still he's
pushing 90. whatever the [ __ ] i don't
i don't know anything about politics i'm
gonna stay out of it but i will i
i will say this this is my prediction
being a fan of sports a sports
fan i say
that the the whoever they declare
victory
and then they'll be like this big you
know something it's i don't know next
few days they're going to say
so and so what right whoever loses
is gonna fight it i think biden will
fight it the way they're gonna fight it
trump's gonna sue that's that's what he
does
he's that [ __ ] guy who was near an
accident and all of a sudden he pulls
out a neck brace you know one of those
guys
uh my prediction is that whoever they
declare
won it uh
initially they're gonna stick with that
they'll be out after further review the
play stands you know
touchdown for so and so right and people
are gonna boo and all that [ __ ] because
i believe i believe i can fly no i
believe that um
that if they actually were to
investigate
the entire election right now the amount
of [ __ ] that they would be digging up on
both sides
it would be so [ __ ] ugly to get
exposed that
they just it's just like let's let's
just let sleeping dogs lie
let's this is this isn't going to be
good for anybody
and then my favorite thing is all the
urban myths that are coming up
they found a dumpster uh full of votes
is that somebody at the post office who
just doesn't want to do their job
because like how do you know who voted
for who on the inside and then people
are going well
well biden said vote absentee and trump
said
don't vote absentee so i was just like
oh my god
unbelievable you know i can't believe
that something that's so [ __ ]
dishonest and corrupt could be this
dishonest and corrupt i mean that's
basically what the only thing you can
you're left to say
so um but here's the thing if they say
biden one
one right and trump
becomes a lame duck who's now gonna sue
uh there are gonna be movies made
about what the [ __ ] that guy does if he
if if
he thinks that he's out after just four
years
which i think in politics that's that's
a smudge against your name
was only a one-term president which i
don't understand why because the last
two one-term presidents i liked i liked
jimmy carter and uh i liked the first
bush
um
i don't know i guess
it's a big [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] show
i heard you know what i heard there was
a guy and he just he [ __ ] blah but
like this
is i remember way back on 9 11 all of
that [ __ ] happened you know
i was in new york city on 9 11 right
and i remember there was a rumor going
around town that either a firefighter or
a person in the building
rode the building down and survived
and i actually started to repeat it
until i really just thought of the
physics of that that you could somehow
go from the 80th floor down to the first
floor
in all of seven seconds how the human
body could survive that
and then i just started going like did
that didn't happen
it's like don't you think they would be
interviewing that person they would
interview that person for the rest
of time maybe anytime any of this
[ __ ] i heard there's a dumpster full
of [ __ ] uh
paper eating geese that they just sent
it to the [ __ ] out shut up
is that what you heard my favorite one
though
did you see um
did you see that that [ __ ] guy the
fat guy there
he said it said uh something like
barbecue
booze and freedom and there was some
sort of press conference and he comes up
it's the funniest [ __ ] ever because you
know he thinks he's going to be stopped
and nobody stops him so he's just like
stop the biden crime family from
stealing the election
stop the biden fight crime file if
you're stealing the election the media
is covering it up
it's not the biden family he just kept
saying it and you know this guy came
over to make sure he didn't
do anything to the person who was
supposed to be speaking into the
microphone but nobody stopped him and
then he didn't know what to do
and you know what it reminded me of do
you know you know he could go to i was
joking about my buddies about this dude
you know when you go to a concert and at
the end of the concert you know that
feeling when you don't know if it's over
or not
like are they coming back out for an
encore
the light's gonna a lot of people are
leaving is this stupid of you still
standing here
[Laughter]
it was sort of that it was sort of that
but the guy is like the [ __ ] passion
the guy has
in his his shirt i just love that his
his tank top
shirt is it's like
i just love that he's not wearing it
ironically
you know he believes in all of that [ __ ]
you can't you can't get [ __ ] mad at
that there's a zen
simplicity to that right
whereas out here in [ __ ] douchey l.a
somebody would be wearing that
you know to make fun of a guy like that
right without putting himself out there
that's what bugs me about those those
people that wear [ __ ] ironically oh i
don't mean any of this
well what do you mean nothing
i hide behind these things i know you
guys are sick of these [ __ ] stories
but i i [ __ ] up my shoulder again
i went too fast it's again this time
it's a god
i'm just done i'm done i'm gonna go find
one of these [ __ ] quack doctors out
here
that you know they send your blood to
germany and then they spin it
you know what i mean is they play like a
hitler speech or something like that and
then you come [ __ ] back
and you know they put the blood back in
you and all of a sudden you got like
[ __ ]
shoulders like lee mages you're the
bionic man i'm just doing that i
i don't have i don't have the the
[ __ ]
knowledge to rehab these things and god
knows when you go on the [ __ ]
internet you can't find anything
which is why it's so [ __ ] stupid that
people go on the internet
to find information everything on the
internet is presented as fact
that's why every everybody believes the
[ __ ] that they're [ __ ] reading
you know be listening to this stuff
right
there's no facts on what i'm saying
other than i'm just trying to do
something
uh all right if donald trump loses and
becomes a lame duck
i say he overturns roe v wade i don't
know how he'll do it but he'll figure
out a way he overturns that
um he'll increase the taxes in every
[ __ ] state
that went blue
um he'll refuse to leave
i think you remember when uh uh dave
portnoy barstool went [ __ ] limp at
the super bowl i think that that's what
[ __ ] trump's gonna do they're gonna
have to carry him out
and he's just been going they stole the
house this is sad
i think it's gonna be that while joe
biden will stand there with the smirk on
his face
you know hopefully realizing what is
happening
[Laughter]
oh my god i don't know what to believe
because
i got a buddy of mine who really knows
politics and he goes
he goes bill it's not that they're
getting rid of trump he goes
trying to get rid of trump it's that
they think they're going to get
something better
that these are better people and he
started like
running down the list of uh biden and uh
what's her face say what's her name
kamala
how the [ __ ] do i know her name it's
unbelievable like it
how big the presidency is someone who
doesn't pay attention i actually know
well i know mike pence but he's sort of
being there he's sort of a series
regular
recurring character isn't it all right
hang on a second
joe biden
kamala harris there we go
so my buddy's going like dude joe biden
was the guy who was behind that thing if
a black guy
like uh got caught with half a joint he
went to jail for the rest of his life
and kamala refused to let prisoners out
to the point she had to get sued because
she didn't want to lose the labor
i'm like that's true and he's telling
yeah it's [ __ ] who these people are
it's like jesus christ
and i think we gotta we need a youth
movement in
in this this country i really believe
that
it's always like old people running for
presidents because they're protecting
old money
and if you've been a diabolical son of a
[ __ ] the older you are the longer
you've done it if you haven't gone to
jail if you're on the legal side of
stealing the white side
um you can really
accrue this amazing fortune
but you know you need to try and protect
it so i think that they just get these
old guys in there
you know and then they just play like
songs from their generation when they
sell them on it like way back in the day
you know they probably just
you know when they talk to nixon and
[ __ ] lyndon johnson they would play
play
you know they play little [ __ ] benny
goodman in the background and they would
just sell them on if you do this
and do that and do this and then someday
you know
you'll get a [ __ ] mansion on martha's
vineyard at the end of this which is
what every politician
i believe in the democrat and the
republican party are going for
you know the people who you vote for who
you're allegedly wasting your vote i
really believe that those people
you know i i'd like to think i think no
i think right now they care about
american people if the libertarian party
was to get as big
as the democrat and the republican party
they would eventually they would
eventually sell out too
that's kind of what i find with um
in my business so i'm just going to
apply that if if a company is new that
the suits will just be like hey man like
you're the creative
person like we don't we don't know
anything of you just create just make
some
content just like we just want to see
your artistry bloom
right and then they get a little bigger
and then they're kind of like well you
know i don't know about you
he said here's our input could you do a
little more like this and then the final
wave is [ __ ] you we own everything
you do what we say or uh you'll never
work in this town again that is the
trajectory
of of everything agency or whatever
in this town we're just a little
boutique agency and we're just gonna
send you on this independent stuff and
kick it
in look if you don't wanna do a
superhero movie and uh watch me take a
shower get the [ __ ] out of our agency
you know
it's it's it's an old tale
you know you know it's like me when i
first started doing this podcast way
back in 2007 i had my hat in hand i was
just happy that you were listening
you know now what i do i sit here and i
sip throat coat t and i try to tell you
about [ __ ]
politics i mean i don't know who the
[ __ ] i think i am but somewhere along
i don't know i kind of went off the
rails here um
so anyway i got my uh
i had an acting gig yesterday it was
kind of a nice thing to do the day of
the election
just not be there and uh
everybody was just like
us the amount of people that told me is
like dude i couldn't even watch it i
don't i don't want to know either way
i had a joke in 2016 i was saying
hillary versus trump is like [ __ ] 2
a.m at the bar
you got to find someone to go home with
this is another one of those
back to back where the [ __ ]
where's the young cool guy there was
always the young cool guy
the jfk guy would come along the gary
hart you know
[ __ ] bill clinton and al gore would
show up with their [ __ ]
their their jean jackets on to show how
young and hip they are right
you know you know they're in their
[ __ ] mid 40s then they play some
fleetwood mac don't
stop thinking about tomorrow and you're
like oh my god
that was song they played at my prom and
then you just voted for him
and then the old guy got kicked out
they've been doing that
forever democrats i guess have been
doing that the republicans always seem
to wheel out a really [ __ ] old guy
right well no george w bush wasn't old
they fought youth with youth with that
right
um then what was the next one
then it was obama versus uh george w
bush
that was you know what something i don't
know what the [ __ ] i'm talking about but
that's what i would have done
i would have just brought out the
[ __ ] young guy you know that the
chicks are all just like i don't know
i just believe him that's all you needed
um with a mike pence kind of [ __ ]
level of hair except your diet
and then a few people be like can't
trust nobody dyes their hair
um there's always a reason right there's
always a reason so
anyway i actually had a really good time
yesterday i always have a little bit of
anxiety before i go into a [ __ ]
acting set i always do
i always think like oh god i'm gonna
[ __ ] this up this is gonna take all day
i'm gonna make them be behind and then
they're gonna be like well he's doing
good enough
job just [ __ ] get them through it or
whatever and then i always go in and i
always end up having a great time and
that's what ended up happening yesterday
and um i don't know
i just i want a nice little run here i
don't do a lot of acting work but when i
do it i have a good time so i want to
thank everybody
that let me work yesterday during a
pandemic
and um i only have one big job left this
year and i'm done
i gotta write an episode of f is for
family
that's what i'm doing over the next
couple of weeks which is always fun
um we almost have the fifth season all
written if you can believe it
the fifth and final season
really sad about that but you know what
it's going to open up a new door
i'll walk through that door and look at
the wonderment of what's in there and
then wonder where my money went
[Music]
that's why i love stand up that's why i
love thank god for stand up and
podcasting
you know
everything else i just look at it like
yeah they're gonna take this away this
is gonna go away this is all just a
mirage
um all right let me do a little bit of
uh
some reads here you know what [ __ ]
sucks man i had i'd taped
like four football games you know that's
my move i don't know if you guys are new
to the podcast some of you out there
that's my move on sunday
i tape four extra games i watch two or
three games and i tape four other ones
all right so then i have a game to watch
on tuesday wednesday friday and saturday
so every [ __ ] day of the week i can
watch an nfl football game
i also watch seven football games a week
i'm have this is that i'm having the
time of my [ __ ] life during this
pandemic
because usually half the season i'd be
gone every other weekend i go out and
work do my little jokes
what's up with that look at my dick
talking about [ __ ]
go [ __ ] yourself all women i'm not
misogynistic
right that's my act so um
that's what i would usually do and uh
i don't have to do that now so now i'm
getting my my full [ __ ] money
my full [ __ ] money's worth on uh
uh with all the sports packages watched
all the nhl a little bit of the nba
you know what's going to be funny uh
when they make the the last dance
for nba players of today because you
know they all want one
you know enough of them enough of them
have big enough egos where they were
watching the last dance and were like yo
this is like me except it's michael
jordan and the funniest thing about
theirs
is that epic moment in it where they go
where like i couldn't
i couldn't get past the pistons
and then they got to dig down deeper and
lift weights and figure out how to
[ __ ] get tougher mentally and
physically
be a better teammate be just as good
defensively as you are offensively all
that nah
is that what you did no so the next
season i joined the detroit pistons and
then
i was a champion and then the whole
thing's going to [ __ ] end
what went in
um all right bill we get it we get it
you miss
you miss i i do i miss people staying on
their [ __ ] teams until they win a
championship that's what i miss
i miss teams that suck get all of a
sudden getting a great player and all of
a sudden they turn it around and then
and then they go on a run
right like the bulls the balls suck
forever and then michael jordan came
there then they were the [ __ ] team
now why would you do that when everyone
can just keep joining the same [ __ ]
three teams
all right um let's do a little podcast
oh i didn't tell you what happened so i
watched the patriots
get their asses quick no it was a great
game
buffalo game was actually a great game
um
so i hit the erase button
and my dvr had all the football games i
taped in the same
like grouping so i thought i was just a
race in that game i
raced four other football games
and my hat sunk because i taped that
uh bengals versus titans i wanted to
watch joe burrow
go up against mike frable's titans and
all of that stuff see how they stopped
uh
the fox's name henry there running back
or whatever at least kept him contained
derek henry um i lost all of those
[ __ ] games i lost my favorite [ __ ]
team to watch
the charges i love watching them always
exciting games even though they seem to
blow it in the end
um [ __ ] bummed out but you know what
they got football tonight let's see
let's see who's on tonight wearing their
rush uniform
thursday look at that right there
thursday night football
bring it to me what do we got come on
something good
thursday night flip not the [ __ ]
banged up 49ers
oh my god at least the 49ers aren't
playing the cowboys like
they both have like third string
quarterbacks right
second or two okay yeah packers first
49ers all right
i guess you got to go you got to go
packers there
in the 49er i think uh was it bosa
posted still on the concussion
protocol um anyway all right
okay we got some breeds here look who it
is everybody it's for him
hymns h-i-m-s hotel india
mike sierra men have tried all kinds of
odd unusual solutions to treat
e.d erectile dysfunction
example snake oil pills herbs
or herbs as they say overseas hypnotism
your dick is rising your dick is rising
the rest of yours getting sleepy but
hymns
dude what the [ __ ] you getting
hypnotized to make your dick stand up i
hope you trust that
hypnotic person uh just
uh i'm a hypnotist that's what it is all
right uh but hymns
offers solutions grounded in real
medical
science for hims.com is all about men's
wellness you need help with erectile
dysfunction
hair loss or have a cold oh my god can
you imagine if you [ __ ] could cure
all those in one day
come out with a lion's mane of hair
breathing like you never breathed before
dick standing up from the halls of
interested in mental health or covet 19
home tests
hymns is here for you jesus christ these
guys they got they got everything
hymns makes it easy hymns connects with
the licensed medical professional online
who can prescribe
fda approved prescription medication to
treat your
erectile dysfunction you get the same
active ingredient and you know if you
actually if your dicks long enough if
you can yell and
erectile dysfunction into the end of it
like a seashell it gradually will uh
you'll wake it up you know and that is
not snake oil
that's [ __ ] all right you get the
same active ingredient
as that expensive little pill but
without the expensive price tag
here we go no embarrassing conversations
no expensive appointments just answer a
few questions online
about your medical history and a prof
and a provider will confidentially
do they make your dick stand back up
full head of hair cure your cold
see if you got covered i mean you're
[ __ ]
you're ready to start your weekend
you can confidently answer all my dick's
working i don't have covered
i think tonight i'll pot it down the
middle uh no embarrassing conversations
i'm sorry sir what did you say said my
dick doesn't work what i i can't hear
you i said my dick doesn't work
uh no expensive appointments just answer
a few questions
online about your medical history and a
provider will confidently review
if approved your medication is shipped
freely no
shipped directly to your door in
discreet packaging and shipping is free
no more searching online for answers to
questions about erectile dysfunction
or sexual wellness um
just go to for you know reminds me of
his marvin gaye sexual healing
you know he came up with that he was
talking about all the perverted stuff he
was doing and how
empty and dark he felt afterwards and
his friend just like man
you need like a sexual healing and he
was like
that is the name of a song i am not
going to therapy i'm going to write a
[ __ ]
hit song and have some more groupie sex
um just go to for him's account and ask
a medical professional
professional uh you can trust why
live with erectile dysfunction when the
solution can be so simple try hymns
today by starting out with a free online
visit
go to for hims.com bird b-u-r-r-e-d
get it burr erectile dysfunction um
bravo uniform romeo romeo erectile
dysfunction
bird for your free visit
that's for hims.com bird f o
r h i m s dot com slash bird
products are subject to medical provider
approval and require an online
consultation
with a medical provider who will
determine if a prescription is
appropriate
see website for all for full details and
safety information
remember that remember that's for
hims.com
slash burst mafia he's they're stealing
the election
we want our freedom um fight camp
fight camp all right the first rule
about fight camp is you talk about fight
camp on the podcast
uh do you get bored with your workouts
if you're looking for something that
keeps you engaged
motivated and challenged you got to
check out fight camp
fight camp brings the boxing gym to you
with a mix of catio
and conditioning for a full body workout
wouldn't you like to be in the shape of
a prize fighter without getting punched
in the head well this is how you do it
it comes with all the gear you need the
best freestanding punching bag on the
market
all right enough about your girlfriend
oh jay-z
what do you want what the i mean the
emotional punching bag people
uh great boxing gloves quick
hand wraps and their unique punch
tracking sensors that show
you real-time progress and stats on any
ios device i always forget what that
means
what is it internet operating service
ios ios meaning
ios mobile operating system well that
makes
that makes sense that totally makes
sense
mobile starts with the letter i
um where am i here
okay you can learn you can you can learn
you can't learn
either way you're gonna figure it out
you can learn from six highly qualified
trainers ranging from a pro mma fighter
oh wow and mother of two
to a kickboxing world champion dude how
cool is that mma fighter
slash mother of two tell me that house
is [ __ ]
not safe and everybody's listening to
their mom oh my god can you imagine that
imagine if you mouthed off to your
mother and she put you in a triangle
all right all right take out the trash
uh you'll have access to over 400
different workouts for all fitness
levels
and skills with four new ones every week
what's the matter mike my mom choked me
out again last night
she's such a jerk fight camp offers
flexible financing for as low
as zero percent apr annual percentage
rate
and right now as a limited time offer
you can try
fight camp for 30 days with their money
back guaranteed just go to fightcamp.com
bird that's right try fight camp for 30
days and if you don't love it
they'll refund your money train like a
fighter and turn your sweat into results
to try to this is a classic before and
after photo
workout man to try fight camp
for 30 days just go to
jointfightcamp.com join
join fightcamp.com b-u-r-r
oh look who it is everybody look who it
is it's
old zip
stop counting the votes uh businesses
have tried to be flexible this year
from working remotely to pivoting their
business models
for long-term survival and growth share
some of your own examples of the
following
restaurants are moving their dining
outdoors and adding takeout and catering
well i don't own a restaurant but i've
eaten it one
i'm not a doctor but i play one on tv i
i've eaten at restaurants outside
you know i enjoy it
okay some
consumer packaged goods companies have
shifted to focus more on surface
cleaners or personal hygiene products i
have not had experience with that
major retailers are now selling face max
i've seen that
i saw this lady sitting on the side of
the road with their masks all
laying on these [ __ ] bars the the the
banisters you know as you walk up the
stairs i have seen that
those are my personal experiences if
you're in charge of hiring for your
business
these pivots have made your job even
more challenging especially
if you have to hire for brand new roles
yeah you don't know what you're going to
get
thankfully there's one place that you
can always count on to make hiring
faster and easier it's all
zip
[Music]
code dot com slash burp
uh when you put when you post a job on
ziprecruiter
it gets sent to over 100 top job boards
with one
click then zip a
powerful technology finds people with
the right skills and experience for your
job and actively invites them to apply
yeah people this is business you don't
have time to be [ __ ] around trying to
find somebody
you just hit one click boom it's out
there and then your qualified candidate
shows up wrapped up in a bow it's no
wonder that four or five
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day
they can't even count the [ __ ] votes
in one day see for yourself right now
and you can try zip uh for free
at ziprecruiter.com that's
ziprecruiter.com
spell out burr b-u-r-r let zip recruiter
take hiring off your plate
so you can focus on growing your
business go to zip
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
all right and we're back
spread your way back
you know what song i've had in my my
head for like the last [ __ ] i don't
know how many days
like 10 days that bad company song
and i don't even know the words i just
go walking down the winding road
something something something and then
something else
[ __ ] something else
ready for love i gotta get to i at least
i at least have to know the [ __ ]
words i'm gonna be singing this ready
for love
lyrics india re oh my god how old am i
it's bad company somebody else came
along and had the nerve to have the name
the same song
all right oh it is walking down this
rocky road
wondering where my life
is [ __ ] leading that's not what they
say rolling on
the bitter end oh
ooh i want you to stay
ready for love sorry that's a little bit
out of my register
anything that involves singing is a
little out of my register all right
everybody that is the podcast
i want to hear your predictions get him
in early
who do you think's going to win and why
and if the person you don't want to win
wins
i want to know how the other person
cheated i want to hear your conspiracy
theories
i want to hear about the dumpsters with
liberals in them
[ __ ] [ __ ] on trump votes i want
to hear
donny's got his uh he's got a bunch of
red dumpsters out there that say make it
great again
that everybody's ripping up i want to
hear it
i want to hear it i want to hear about
the rothschilds and how they i want to
hear the whole [ __ ] thing all right
that's it all right people that's the
podcast tonight if i am a batting man
lord i was born a bit and man uh i got
to go with the packers tonight
i got to go with the packers because i
think the 49ers are just too goddamn
banged up
unless that number's too big let's see
what we got here
packers verse 49ers
um packers versus 49ers
uh line let's see what we got here
packers giving [ __ ] five and a half
i'd take that all day
although that low of a number scares me
because i think they're going to kill
him
all right that is the [ __ ] podcast
everybody enjoy your weekend your [ __ ]
don't watch the news
there's no reason to watch the news
until they're just [ __ ] they'll tell
you
when they when they're done counting
them all right they'll just tell them
and other than that just you know
get on with your life be a nice person
affect the change in your world shut up
bill okay
sorry enjoy the music and there'll be a
bonus
uh thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast right after this
from like i know
a few years ago okay all right thank you
bye-bye
hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
the monday morning podcast
for monday november 5th 2012
how's it going how are you as you can
tell this is once again
one of these ones i'm doing from the
road i don't have a mixer
i was supposed to buy a really small one
but then i went to
um i don't know i bought this giant one
like i guess it was gonna sound better
than my other one i don't [ __ ] know
but all i know is it's too big to take
on the road and then i was gonna buy a
small one
but i'm here in new orleans and they i
don't know i don't know where to [ __ ]
buy one in new orleans
and i know all you [ __ ] who are from
new orleans are like dude what the [ __ ]
there's a zillion places you know
that have music yeah well where are they
okay i don't know where they're at
i don't know what to [ __ ] look up and
uh and i got i got to be honest with you
like you know new orleans
is it's a great city but it's one of the
shadiest
i put it up there in like my top maybe
four or five shady cities that i go to
you know if you'd like the list in no
particular order
it would be uh san jose
is shady uh downtown cincinnati past
five o'clock these all these all these
cities past five o'clock is shady
cincinnati uh detroit all day
all day detroit all day cleveland
is that five except for to add to
[ __ ] new orleans
this is the one thing i will say as
[ __ ] up as san jose cincinnati
cleveland and detroit are just as far as
being like i don't feel
safe past 5 p.m because anybody with who
actually has ever filled out a w-2 form
seems to go home
at 501 uh before that second
shift of [ __ ] zombies hustlers and uh
god knows
[ __ ] werewolves come out um
i would say new orleans
i i can't put my finger on it it's got
this great music it's got great people
but it just has that you know you're
gonna get your throat slit
if you go down the wrong [ __ ] street
vibe
it really does and this is what they
don't have in their little tourist
you know [ __ ] brochure because it is
great
and you can you know go on a [ __ ]
riverboat
you can go down to bourbon street which
really bourbon street is really like
that's the times square of new orleans
like nobody from new orleans
i figured that out in about [ __ ] 10
minutes
when i went over to bourbon street with
[ __ ] paul
dude i called it verzi i was over there
for like
first of all stone sober when i went
down the street and it's just that the
whole vibe of that street
you know it just says sex offender
sucker punched um
hepatitis those would be the three you
know like if i was on the ten thousand
dollar pyramid
those those would be the clues that i
was uh sucker punched
uh uh herpes uh
uh uh dirty needle pass
pass let's go to the neck we'll come
back to it um
i [ __ ] hate doing these without
headphones to the point i'm actually
wearing headphones and i can't even hear
myself it's like my [ __ ] linus
security blanket
but anyways new orleans is the [ __ ] the
food is amazing
but um at night i have to tell you like
it's the only city in america that if
i actually came face to face with a
vampire like i wouldn't be surprised
you know it's got voodoo you know i
forgot that that's what really puts it
over the top i would say the voodoo
you know voodoo
i don't even believe in that [ __ ] i
don't believe in any of that [ __ ]
but it's just the fact that somebody
does and whenever you see those things
on
on voodoo on tv they always have like
that
crazed speaking in tongues look on their
face
you know some chick always has their
titties out
and she dumps the blood of a chicken all
over it's just [ __ ] you know it's
what are you doing that's like manson
family [ __ ]
you know what i mean like if charles
manson somehow got out of jail
and started running nbc and wanted to
bring back that whole must-see
tv thing that they had they used to have
back in the late 90s
the first [ __ ] pilot he would green
light would be anything that had to do
with voodoo
you know hey wait has that ever been
done
a sitcom around like a voodoo person
that would really be terrible it would
take all the [ __ ] edge out of it um
anyways this is the monday morning
podcast for this week as i mentioned a
few weeks ago
about a month ago um i started my own uh
podcast i guess radio station i guess
you'd call it
podcast network with uh al madrigal and
some other smarty pants
a lot smarter than i am and uh it's
called allthingscomedy.com
and oh we have a bunch of wonderful
shows on there if you want to check it
out we're gradually going to be adding
to the site
where we'll actually have things beyond
just the podcast we're going to start
blogging
start putting videos up and all that
type of stuff this is the early times
you know like aerosmith's first record
you know they didn't quite have the
aerosmith emblem
drawn the way it is now it was sort of a
simpler form of it
you know took them till they got to
about toys in the attic maybe
after get your wings they still had that
same one
and now what now you want that old
concert t-shirt with their original logo
well this is the original logo
allthingscomedy.com and uh i got i'm
gonna try to
do uh re uh ari shafir skeptic tank i'm
gonna actually
i'm actually gonna you're gonna hear
that i'm gonna text him about it before
he even [ __ ] knows how about that
that's how inside you guys are
but anyways um the brilliant tom rhodes
part of the all things comedy network
has a one-hour special
called light sweet crude that just
became available on netflix last week
this guy's [ __ ] hilarious
harlan williams from harlan highway has
a new mobile app called
harland app h a r capital l a nd
app it's available on itunes via
harlandapp.com
and uh mazda brawny's crowd
funding campaign for his movie jimmy
vestwood
american hero um described as the pink
panther meets coming to america here's
the link
to the campaign it's crowdfunding uh you
know i'm gonna put the link up it's too
[ __ ] long
all right so there you go there's the
plugs back to the podcast back to the
[ __ ] voodoo
so anyways i told you last week that i
was coming out here to new orleans
and i was going to go to bucket list
game i was going to go to [ __ ] new
orl i was going to go to uh baton rouge
the lsu game and [ __ ] uh verse
alabama and uh
it was uh it lit it definitely lived up
to the hype
i'm telling you right now people who
live in pro sports cities like i did
where you look at like you know college
teams
like you know the deal i grew up outside
of boston so i mean we had boston
college
doug flutie was our big moment you know
i know that they've had guys after that
but basically doug flutie put him on the
map and when i was growing up basically
college sports in boston like our
football team
the eagles of the uh the bu terriers
back when they still had a [ __ ] team
they first of all didn't even televise
the bu games
and then the bc games you know we had
one of those teams you know like when
your team goes to kick a field goal
like you can see the dorms you know
you can see like the parking lot and
that type of [ __ ] we didn't have an
enclosed stadium we just had
bleachers on either side and then doug
flutie came and did what he did
and everybody got [ __ ] paid and they
made so much
goddamn money off of that guy that they
actually were able to enclose
you know the stadium you know what i
mean
but you know college athletes shouldn't
get paid
they shouldn't get paid they make enough
[ __ ] money for the
school that they can build a new
football stadium
i love that too when people go college
athletes they get paid
they get a free education free education
[ __ ]
they just built a hundred thousand
[ __ ] seat stadium
because of all my little twinkle toe
activities between the [ __ ] hash
marks
you know i get a degree in business
it's [ __ ] ridiculous i'll tell you
that lsu alabama game there's over a
hundred thousand
[ __ ] people there and by the way we
sat
way the [ __ ] up there we sat there in
that part of the
stadium that they added on to the
original bowl
you know oh it sucks they treat you like
a [ __ ] it's like you're flying in coach
you don't even actually i never actually
technically have ever even been in that
stadium because i never would
with the ticket that i had they oh i
can't go on hot you gotta upload
you know that [ __ ] creole accent and
i like literally had to like walk in the
back door
and i vaguely remember going up i think
like 36 [ __ ]
escalators until i finally got up top
and uh it was still the [ __ ] though
the one thing you can't say when you're
up there is
if you can't [ __ ] read a defense or
figure out what the [ __ ] they're doing
from up there you can see the whole
field
it's phenomenal but uh i gotta be honest
i really
learned how much i love lsu by how
[ __ ] devastated i was when they lost
like versey was beside himself he's like
dude i didn't realize i mean i knew you
were a fan but you were like
dude i was like more pissed off than the
[ __ ] people
the lsu fans i gotta tell you something
lsu fans and alabama fans now there
might be some fans around the fcc i'm
sure are gonna roll their [ __ ] eyes
at this but like as far as their fan
behavior
at the one game that i've been to they
were phenomenal
absolute gentlemen i didn't hear barely
any cursing
uh they were mixed in together you know
the section where i'm up you know up in
the [ __ ] bullpen up there they were
all mixed in together and it was
i was amazed at the behavior
like when it looked like lsu was going
to win the game and some bunch of
alabama fans started leaving like which
i don't know why the [ __ ] he ever would
you know people gave them some [ __ ] you
know thanks for coming
have a nice long ride back to [ __ ]
tuscaloosa you know they'd say [ __ ] like
that that's about as deep as it got
and it's [ __ ] hilarious because i'm
staying here at this casino
where there's a bunch of eagle fans
waiting to go to the saints game tonight
which means version you're going to and
you see the behavior of eagle fans in a
[ __ ] casino
it's 100 times worse than lsu alabama
fans sitting next to each other
yesterday we were sitting there we were
watching sunday football
and all of a sudden you just hear coming
from the casino because everybody's
wearing their jerseys
you know all the dealers are wearing
like saints jerseys and [ __ ]
and all the eagles fans are walking
around with their jerseys on
um and i just hear from [ __ ] the
other side of the casino i just hear
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] and i'm thinking like that those
stones
that sounds like the [ __ ] they do with
the philly games
when they pointed somebody with a
different jersey right and then i just
hear
e a g l e
s eagles like obnoxious is [ __ ] hell
in the casino so me and verzie are
sitting in like this
[ __ ] i don't know how to explain it
it looks like a dance club
that you that you'd go into when you're
playing like grand theft auto
that's what it looked like there was
this big center thing that had these
crazy
like neon lights that which gradually
change
like the background and like bill cosby
himself how the background would just
gradually change color
except on his special he had like four
colors this was only two colors it would
go from red
and then it would just morph into gold
and then back to red look like a giant
[ __ ] glow stick and but there was
like these go go dancer
stages which obviously nobody would say
it was just these [ __ ] fat football
fans
by the way football fans are the most
out of shape [ __ ] creeps you've ever
seen in your life
just bunch of fatties sitting there like
like walruses sunning themselves
you know before they get bit in the neck
by a polar bear right so we're sitting
there
and we're along this bench right and
it's me
versy and then this this this black dude
was sitting there for a second
who sort of had like this african sort
of had a voodoo vibe he had like this
[ __ ]
uh old school like you know like uh run
dmc one
well cool j when they had the big gold
chains he had a big chain like that but
it was plastic
and it was made out of yellow just
yellow plastic
like a fisher price my first mc
chain he was wearing and he was wearing
that as like a [ __ ] 40 year old guy
or he looked 40. the guy looked like he
had a rough life
and he had all his teeth from
what's that number nine over your two
front teeth are eight and nine
starting from the right going over up
top for those of you who never worked in
a dental office so he had number nine
all the way to the back and from [ __ ]
eight to the other side was just
completely missing
like he took like a mike tyson [ __ ]
hook
back in 1988. so
frizzy goes up to the bar and that dude
kind of came over voodoo guy
sits down and i'm going like f i don't
want to talk to this [ __ ] voodoo dude
but i'm going to look like a [ __ ] if i
don't when versi comes back if when this
[ __ ] half a vampire's sitting here
with this plastic chain so i just tapped
him and i just said hey excuse me my
buddy's sitting here
and he kind of gave me a look just long
enough for me to be like
am i gonna [ __ ] fight this guy
am i gonna have the weirdest bite marks
on my forearm ever
where they won't even know what the [ __ ]
bit me
and then he slid over thank god then of
course verzi whose all personality
comes over and sits down next to the guy
and immediately they're shooting the
[ __ ] like they went to [ __ ] war
together right
so eventually the voodoo guy gets up and
leaves
and uh then we kind of got this whole
like bench area to ourselves
like cushion bench tonight you know
watching the [ __ ] games
having a good time uh and then this
other dude comes over
another black dude don't worry
eventually i'll be making fun of a white
dude so this doesn't seem like it's just
[ __ ]
me being freaked out by black people and
this guy comes over
and he looked like thurman thomas like
how thurman thomas would look now
and you know those people when they sit
down they never stop rocking
he he was doing that he was just sitting
there [ __ ] rocking
just back and forth kind of doing this
ocd thing with his fingers
and then like muttering to himself right
and he was sitting
like we're on this giant bench of
cushion so he's he's like there's one
empty cushion between versey and this
guy and verse he's so
locked into the game he's watching the
giant steelers
that he doesn't see this [ __ ] dude
like rocking back and forth
and i'm laughing my ass off
so finally because i keep seeing people
wanting to sit down in that seat and
then they see this dude [ __ ] thurman
thomas the old thurman [ __ ] rocking
back and forth
i'm gonna steal the giants they're doing
this [ __ ] rain man [ __ ] and i'm
laughing my ass off and i thought versey
sub
so write his verse he's taking a swig of
his drink i said hey versa you see that
guy there and he looks over at him he
does almost does a spit take
i go he's the human equivalent of you
know those things at the airport that
are always spinning to keep the [ __ ]
birds off the runway so they don't fly
into the engine
he's literally the human equivalent of
that preventing anyone from sitting in
that seat
and right as i get done saying that this
[ __ ]
eagles fan comes over with the t-shirt
on
astronaut haircut and just [ __ ] like
like movie drunk right overacting drunk
stumbling over and [ __ ] just sits
down
like like on [ __ ] one ass cheek
totally lean in his head
he starts sliding down almost in
diversity first he's like whoa whoa whoa
hey easy easy
and then this [ __ ] the two worlds
collides
this [ __ ] guy like i don't know what
he did if he like shotgun some whiskey
or if he actually took some drugs
because he was [ __ ] out of it
starts tapping uh rain man thurman
thomas
he taps him and like
the way this dude was rocking and
talking to himself i wouldn't even think
that he could have a [ __ ]
conversation
but the second this [ __ ] drugged up
eagles fan
tapped [ __ ] rain man thurman thomas
the dude just
snapped out of it and was like a [ __ ]
state trooper he just looked at the dude
and and the [ __ ] eagles fans like
said something like you know
i said how you doing or how you living
or something
and the dude just looked at me and he
was like how you living and he had this
[ __ ] look on his face like this
pissed off look
and the kid tried to high-five him and
the guy all of a sudden he he just
looked like he was gonna he had like
that special needs strength
and was literally just gonna [ __ ]
punch this kid's lower jaw
fortunately that didn't happen and
rayman thurman thomas slid over one more
chair so now we got this [ __ ] guy
and he keeps passing out falling on into
versi and then he try and high-five us
and uh we finally ended up having to get
security he felt like [ __ ] but it
was just like
he was gonna puke he could just tell he
was gonna puke on somebody so the
security came over
eventually got rid of him so then verzi
because he's missed a personality
has to talk to [ __ ] you know
thurman [ __ ] dustin hoffman right and
he goes
he said something about the guy
hey you know hey that guy was uh he
seemed like he was pretty drunk he
seemed like he was gonna puke
and the [ __ ] rain man dude stopped
[ __ ] rocking and looked at him he go
he looked like he gonna get his ass
kicked
and we were like all right all right man
nice talking to you and then immediately
went right back to just sitting there
[ __ ] rocking
i couldn't figure the guy out either had
you know either had some sort of mental
problem or he had like [ __ ] 20 grand
on the game
that he didn't have i don't know was
that even remotely [ __ ] amusing i
have no idea i'm [ __ ] sitting here
with headphones on
i can't hear myself um this is the
monday morning podcast by the way
uh what the [ __ ] i gotta do i gotta do
two quick advertisements for this week
uh here we go stamps.com everybody you
know the deal if you don't want to go to
the post office anymore you can have the
post office right inside your own
dwelling
with stamps.com you can buy and print
official us postage using your own
computer
printer whatever you need it 24 7.
no more wasting time at the post office
what a hassle man
no need to lease an expensive meter
stamps.com offers more features than a
meter
and at a fraction of the price plus
stamps.com
customers receive special discounts on
mailing and shipping
you can't even get at the post office uh
on priority mail express mail
and even more no wonder stamps.com
customers have already printed over
three billion dollars in postage iu
stamps.com whenever i send out my dvds
to my gigs i never have a problem i feel
like a little professional i feel like
i'm getting away with something
um use my last name bur b-u-r-r for my
special offer no risk trial
plus 110 bonus offer that includes a
digital scale and up to 55 dollars in
free postage
they're just giving you 55 bucks and a
scale
huh who else does that nobody stamps.com
don't wait go to stamps.com before you
do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in burr burr that
stamps dot com
enter bur all right back to the podcast
so anyways
um me and [ __ ] go to lsu
alabama on say
saturday for those of you not from
boston and um
what was i going to say i was actually
just talking about going you know i was
like what the [ __ ] ever happened to make
a load light
it's the first beer i ever got drunk off
of i don't give a [ __ ] who you are you
got
there's a special thing you know it's
like the first chick you ever [ __ ]
nailed
the first beer you ever got drunk off of
i had
i had like i think i had like two mick
lights the first time i ever caught a
ball
a buzz in faneuil hall in boston
and i was like oh i think i like this
smash cut
[ __ ] 30 years later um
so anyways we're we're here in new
orleans and we actually went to this
[ __ ] shady liquor store
to buy a styrofoam cooler and all that
crap and uh lo and behold versi comes
out with some michelob light and a
bottle of jameson
and the whole night before we're at the
show
and everybody in the crowd i'm like oh
now it's going to be 100 000 people it's
a [ __ ] seven o'clock game what time
should we leave
and they're like six in the morning
seven in the morning i'm like get the
[ __ ] out of here there's not gonna be 12
hours of traffic
and they just kept laughing at me acting
like it was gonna be this apocalyptic
[ __ ] traffic
and i just kept thinking you know i go
to the rose bowl every year that's a
hundred thousand [ __ ] people
yeah there's traffic but like it's not
to that level and i get there four or
five hours before the game
these people are full of [ __ ] you know
and there's no way that
with the way i drink which i believe is
called binge drinking there's no way i'm
gonna be able to get there 12 hours
before the game i'll pass out three
times before the game even starts and by
then i'm not going to give a [ __ ]
so we ended up leaving around 1 30.
[ __ ] cruise to the game
made a left off some exit right before
the [ __ ] stadium
we just parked on a side street
actually if you want to know where we
parked we parked on stanford and yale
right in front of somebody's house they
said it was 40 bucks
to park on their lawn but there was a
space in the street so we just [ __ ]
parked there
so then all of a sudden we realized we
were like almost a mile away from the
stadium that we were going to have to
carry this styrofoam cooler
with ice and all these beers in it him
holding one side be holding the other
and it's dennis trading off this bottle
of [ __ ] jameson was going to be
[ __ ] ridiculous
so i got you know why don't we just slam
a couple of these let's take some weight
out of this cooler
i swear to god dude i think i drank five
of those in like 90 minutes which at my
age is impressive
i wasn't shotgunning either or funneling
them like you [ __ ] in college that's
the easy way
you know what i mean i would i [ __ ]
that's ripping off the band-aid i did
the work
so i sucked these things down then of
course then i got a piss like a
racehorse
so i'm drunk enough that my personality
comes out and i don't come off like a
[ __ ] like i did when i was talking to
[ __ ]
thurman thomas there i went up and i
just knocked on the ladies door i said
listen i know i didn't pay to park i
parked in your front yard
is there any way i could use your
bathroom and she was like absolutely
and i went in there when it came out i
gave her five bucks i go
what did i say the uh
uh what the [ __ ] did i say not the home
security fund
the hospitality fund she left she took
the five bucks
right then she comes walking out later
knowing that we're slamming beers out
there and she came out
and she asked for our empties you know
that's what kind of economy we're living
in here that someone's gonna i give
somebody five bucks they let me take a
piss in their house
and then they come out and they collect
my empties that's how bad it is
by the way if you live in new york city
or you live in los angeles and you can't
deal with how [ __ ] liberal it is
there you should come down to [ __ ]
baton rouge
and go to an sec football game uh you
you would be in heaven
they what they were saying out there
they were saying
lsu fans a couple of them they were
going no bama
no bomber
then they would trash them for saying
roll tide
what would they say they would say
around the bowl and down the hole
roll tide roll and they would then they
would literally
mime them going down the toilet in case
you didn't get what the [ __ ] they were
saying
um by the way i i actually
um i i've always liked alabama too you
know and i know it's gonna freak out lsu
fans i'm not from here so like
i just like teams that are good so i
actually like teams in the sec that
don't like each other but lsu is my
[ __ ] squad
um and believe me i [ __ ] realized
that when they lost
and uh oh you know what it was too i
didn't like the way the alabama fans
dressed
it reminded me of tcu come on frogs
would they do that [ __ ] where they dress
all dressed like these [ __ ] junior
banker date rapists
they go to a football game right
they wear like they wear dockers
boat shoes and then they have like a
[ __ ] polo shirt that they tuck in
they i swear to god
it's like are you serious right now
you're from alabama
who who you kidding i could see if you
took off your alabama [ __ ]
and you went to someplace else you tried
to pull it off
but eventually people are gonna know
you're from alabama
and don't even [ __ ] with me i've been to
alabama the civilized parts
okay i didn't go down to making a mobile
or all that [ __ ] [ __ ] where they
they're down there i mean i don't even
think they know martin luther king's
dead yet they're probably still having
[ __ ] meetings that's [ __ ] up but
they probably
are we gotta get him why do you think
they took over the nba
he's got to be somewhere he's like elvis
man he ain't dead yet
you know as [ __ ] up as that is i swear
to god
anyways why it just you know and there
was this one
this one [ __ ] dude behind us all
right he had little
seventh grade boy arms and he [ __ ]
you should have seen him
right he's got his little [ __ ]
dockers on in his stupid [ __ ]
shoes he hit he has his gut
the funny thing was this kid was
probably only about 15 pounds overweight
but you could tell that he wasn't
stopping
and i was saying diversity i go look at
that i go look at that dude
i go just tell me that guy doesn't
scream
massive heart attack in about 20 years
and verdi's laughing i go look at his
shoes those are heart attack shoes
he had like these [ __ ] like they were
like boat shoes but
they they had like those tassels on them
i'm gonna tell you right now if you're a
white guy and you wear shoes with
tassels
there's no [ __ ] way you're not gonna
have you have a 98
chance of having a heart attack the
second you put those shoes on
and if you don't have socks on it's a
hundred percent
that is the official dying at your desk
or almost dying at your desk [ __ ]
shoes
you know like you know how chuck
taylor's back in the day with the
official punk rock [ __ ] uh
sneakers that meant you were into punk
music and you were different
because you and all your friends dressed
exactly the same
[Laughter]
those [ __ ] things so anyways
i'm watching the game and the exact
reason why i became an lsu fan
which was was basically because of the
way les
miles you know the mad hatter the
riverboat gambler whatever you want to
call them
would basically
you know i actually said before the game
we're on bourbon street and everybody
was going out even lsu fans were going
to think alabama's going to get us
they're going to
few whom are going they're going to kill
us and
um i i was drunk of course
what else would i be doing and i was
like let me tell you something right now
i'm calling this right now paul versi
there's going to be a fake kick an
onside kick
a fake field goal and a fake punt he's
going to pull out all the tricks
and they're going to [ __ ] win you
watch well
they did the fake field goal they did
the onside kick no fake punt but they
also went for it on fourth down
and if you didn't see the highlights
none of it worked
the onside kick worked but it didn't go
10 yards and uh
oh jesus they [ __ ] blew it i was
absolutely
i couldn't believe i was [ __ ]
devastated i i literally i walked out of
the stadium
it was the quietest i've ever heard on a
thousand people leave a stadium
and i gotta give it to the alabama fans
they weren't talking [ __ ] they were just
like
i i think i was sort of the eagles fan
at the game i was the [ __ ]
i was just walking around [ __ ]
hammered
hammered yelling at anybody i saw in red
i would just go hey alabama
the dream ends tonight
it's gonna be a long ride i just kept
saying that
alabama and they would look at me like
with this [ __ ] shocked look on their
face
and i was like geez did you see that
[ __ ] guy because i didn't
like realize said i'm only judging them
on one game here i thought you guys
you're
i can't i can't figure southern people
out
you know what i mean they're really nice
really polite really friendly
yet all the other [ __ ]
confederate flags the south's gonna rise
again
the whole you know slavery wasn't that
bad a thing was it or the civil war
wasn't about slavery it was about
representation of the [ __ ] you know
they start doing that [ __ ]
um i don't know can you really fault him
for it though
isn't that kind of like the the same
thing is like when your team
does something douchey like films the
other team that you'll never quite admit
that they actually cheated
oh by the way in defense of my new
england patriots um
i was watching the green bay packers
yesterday um
and i saw i saw what's his face aaron
rodgers goes over to the sidelines
and he [ __ ] goes to talk to his coach
and what does he do
he puts his hand over his mouth when he
goes to talk to him
now why do you think that is why do you
think that is because somehow
the other team could read his lips from
that far away
now because you think for some reason
they actually have the nfl
feed going or maybe just maybe there's a
chance
that they're [ __ ] doing something on
the other side that they're filming that
they're looking through binoculars and
all that [ __ ] horse [ __ ]
i'm sorry i'll i'll defend the patriot
look we [ __ ] cheated what are you
gonna do everybody everybody's doing it
i do the same thing when i defend lance
armstrong
lance i'm strong so anyways i actu i'm
telling this story all over the place
man this is like a tarantino movie right
i started in the middle jump to the
beginning and now i'm at the end i don't
know where i'm at
anyways somewhere in like the third
quarter i got these epic hiccups
and i just couldn't stop and i had them
for the rest of the [ __ ] game through
the night the entire drive home they
went away a couple times and they came
back like literally to the point
i felt like my esophagus was gonna snap
in half
um and then i went to sleep
came home had a pizza i had heartburn so
i figured oh i know i'll use some pizza
dough to [ __ ] absorb
that and uh
i went to bed and i actually got woken
up by hiccups at seven in the morning
and all day yesterday i just i just had
them on and off and on and off and on
and off to the point i
finally looked up what causes hiccups
first of all i didn't even know what
they were i just thought it was when you
swallowed air into your stomach and it
was trying to get out but it couldn't
i didn't know and everybody's telling me
their their their
remedies and that type of [ __ ] so
basically this is what causes
after i've told you this story of what i
did
oh and by the way when i went to the
game i had a
burger i had a sausage po boy i had
m ms and i had something else
and i had already drank five [ __ ]
michelobs in a 90 minutes
and then walked up to the stadium for a
mile walking in the sun and i had a big
gulp
of jameson on ice and then i smoked a
cuban cigar
all in there i don't really [ __ ]
remember the order
and in the midst of all that i was going
alibaba
the dream ends tonight that was a
[ __ ] mess
um and then i got these
epic hiccups so this is what causes
hiccups
um it says a very full stomach
can cause bouts of hiccups that go away
on their own
a full stomach can be caused by
number one eating too much food too
quickly
check drinking too much alcohol
check swelling too much
air check smoking
got you right there buddy uh a sudden
change
in stomach temperature such as drinking
a hot beverage and then a cold beverage
now i didn't do that but i definitely
drank a lot of cold and then smoked
i don't [ __ ] know and the last one
emotional stress
or excitement
is it any wonder i had [ __ ] hiccups
for close to 36 straight hours
i did every [ __ ] thing you could
possibly do
i was like a nerd going right down the
checklist you know
i should have been like rocking back and
forth talking to myself
so basically uh
i'll tell you where the excitement came
in was when i went into the uh
stadium when you come walking through
the hall and i just saw those two lsu
end zones and that tiger eye on the uh
on the 50-yard line and i couldn't
[ __ ] believe i was there
and i'll tell you right now
no [ __ ] if you are in a pro sports
town city and and you never watch
college sports because you know you
can't get into it
you never watched it i've only followed
the pros i'm telling pick a team
pick a team get into it the way i did
and
[ __ ] one year you and your buddies
just take a [ __ ] road trip
tell the ladies to go [ __ ] themselves
go to the game don't drink and eat as
much as i did
but definitely get yourself a nice cigar
and uh
go to the game it'll definitely it'll
definitely be worth it i was
actually i was actually
jealous that i didn't study harder in
high school
and didn't go to a to a uh to a college
like that where
because that's that's the amazing thing
about those is
is like those games are like
they're everything it's like generations
of families are together there's like
many reunions of old drinking buddies
and then there's the existing class
i was just unreal espn game day was
there was [ __ ] insane
it was worth every goddamn cent um
so i don't know if you don't have enough
[ __ ] on your bucket list i would i would
definitely suggest going to an sec game
and don't go to some [ __ ] cupcake
game
in september you know
go go to go to a [ __ ] game like that
where there's like a hundred years of
hatred
i'm telling you it puts red sox yankee
[ __ ] to shame go to go to [ __ ]
michigan ohio state
lsu alabama uh florida georgia
oklahoma texas i'm telling you
i'm telling you all right bill we got it
for [ __ ] sakes we got it
um oh by the way friday night when
friday night when we were doing the show
um paul versey got one of the [ __ ]
funniest heckles and he didn't even hear
it
because the guy did it so southern and
like laid back
versi was talking about some [ __ ] and he
just basically said
the tag was and he was just riffing you
know making it more southern because we
were in front of that crowd he's like
you know i'll blah blah blah blah
he goes i don't give a [ __ ] he goes i'll
kick some fat rednecks ass down the
street
or something like that and then i just
hear in the back of the crowd some dude
goes
trying it
[Laughter]
it was fun it was the greatest and he
sounded like he wasn't even bullshitting
i just love that he was like i'm a fat
redneck come on let's do it
[ __ ] it um speaking of which one of my
favorite shows is coming up because
coming back
of course i don't know the name of it
because i'm an idiot uh
it's the one with those southern guys
cook up the moonshine
on film and they are like ducking behind
trees as the cops come by hoping that
they don't find this still
and it's like dude this is all the
damning evidence they need they don't
need to walk through the woods anymore
they just they have your name they'll
find out where you live and they'll just
drive up and get you
right that show has to be fake
why isn't that guy getting arrested they
don't blot out his face or anything
what's the deal um all right let's get
into this uh
southern connecticut show yeah i'm doing
a college at southern connecticut
university will your material be toned
down because of the college kids
um where my act is right now there's
nowhere to go
i can't really tone it down because the
subjects alone
will probably be considered offensive so
what i'm gonna have to do
is change the intro
of each bit well i'll try and make it
more relatable
where i'll be like hey you know here's
something that might happen to you in 20
years if you don't get married you keep
drinking
but then i'll just do the bit so don't
worry about it if you're thinking about
coming to the show it's going to be in
an adult show
i do a college once every two or three
years
um and i'd be lying to you if i wasn't a
little concerned about this one
i'm a little concerned about this
there's a low pressure system coming in
um tone down hey bill you think you can
tone down the swearing during your
podcast
for who
why why would i want to tone down you
think you can go [ __ ] yourself go go
find another podcast
go to all things comedy and find another
podcast to listen to
i love when people do that [ __ ] people
like you know you know you might want to
consider
like i'm sitting here doing this for you
this isn't for you this is for me
so i don't have any guests just sitting
here talking to myself you decide to
listen you do if you don't i don't give
a [ __ ]
all right this is my [ __ ] uh
this is my job that i can get fired from
you know when you just want to make a
couple extra bucks
you know get out of the house maybe
you're not happy in your relationship
you just you know
you don't like sitting around i want to
do something else
get myself a weekend job oh my god he
works so hard
now sweetie he's sick of you um
no so i won't i won't tone it down
anyways um my weekend
yo so for the past three weeks or so
i have been smoking weed on a normal
and i most say and i and i must say it's
what you're trying to say
life is so much more happier because if
any drama rolls
through rose throw t-h-r-o-w
rolls through i know just let it roll
off and life is so much chiller
i'm just gonna read this how this person
wrote it and life is so much
chiller more need to do this and stop
being so damn uptight
love your monday morning podcast and
have a good day go [ __ ] yourself
are you saying that i need to do that
life is so much
more happer h-a-p-p-e-r
because if any drama roles throw um
look after the way i drank this weekend
i'm gonna give you [ __ ] for using any
sort of substance
i actually need to shut it down i would
never advocate
drinking the way that i drink i wouldn't
all right
i got this weird thing where i'm not an
alcoholic i just [ __ ] love doing it i
mean i can
stop jesus i sound like the classic
alcoholic i can stop whenever i want to
i took a [ __ ] year off i was bored
but i was never sitting there like i
need it man i [ __ ] need it
i just like doing it i like getting
hammered and i like yelling at people in
boat shoes
you know sue me uh but i definitely need
to shut it once you start getting
heartburn
what the [ __ ] i'm sitting there making
fun of these people like they're gonna
have a heart attack isn't heartburn
basically the uh the on-ramp
to major coronary failure oh speaking of
which
i'm reading this book right now eat to
live
and every time i say eat to live i
always think of iron maiden
ace is high every time i say eat to live
i hear bruce dickinson saying fly to
live
live to fly um
oh the 80s anyways
you guys should definitely check out
this book hey would you like me to read
you an excerpt of it
i gotta i gotta read you this let me put
this on pause right here actually you
know what maybe it'll be funny if i just
walk across the room
just hang on a second as i walk across
the room here to
try to find you just busy yourselves
busy yourselves
talk amongst yourselves as i try to find
the book
the [ __ ] is it there it is
there it is here it is okay
everybody take your seats take your
seats we're bet class is back in session
all right so this there's this guy right
he wrote this book joel furman
md all right so you know he's smart
um he wrote this book eat to live
so i hate going to the [ __ ] gym the
only reason why i have to go to the gym
other than gravity pulling my [ __ ]
man tits down to the ground
every goddamn day it never quits unless
you're laying down
you know if you did a [ __ ] headstand
your whole life if you could actually do
that
would your [ __ ] man tits eventually
be in your face
what's the deal um anyways this guy's
basically saying
he used basic you know you know forever
that they've said the problem with the
vegan diet
is that you can't get enough protein
you're not going to get enough protein
and that uh
whatever like vegetables aren't a
complete protein or something like that
you basically you got to have a protein
the size
of your the palm of your hand no bigger
than that make sure it's a lean cut and
yadda yadda yadda this guy's saying it's
all [ __ ]
go to the [ __ ] zoo the most jacked
animal there is a goddamn gorilla you
can't get any more jack than that a
[ __ ] gorilla
is like an nfl linebacker [ __ ] times
they said if you [ __ ] had a a a
gorilla if you could actually make it
bench press
if you could actually make it do it you
know i said get all of that right
how the [ __ ] you're gonna make it do it
right somehow it wanted to do it it
could basically bench press
two tons easy all right that's four
thousand pounds
for you dummies out there for you people
overseas i imagine
that's a bunch of [ __ ] uh whatever
the [ __ ]
measurement you use a bunch of stones
um i think like a stone
because i remember looking it up one
time when i was listening to ac dc's
whole lot of rosie weighing in at about
19 stone that was about 218 pounds i
believe
do the [ __ ] math all right so that's
times five that'd be about a thousand
pounds
so that's like 100 star yeah it's about
what about 400 stone 350 stone i go [ __ ]
yourself
so anyways he's saying you go to the zoo
the grill is the most [ __ ] jacked
animal you're ever going to see
and they eat 80 vegetables 20
fruit now granted i realize i'm not a
[ __ ] gorilla but i tell you i went to
the zoo and i looked the goddamn monkey
in the eye
you look a chimp in the eye and i'm
telling you they're us and we're them
all right we're just we're just a little
little uh little above
or a little below depending on how you
view the environment
you know in all our inventions the
[ __ ]
goddamn mess we've made of the planet so
anyways this is what the guy's claiming
as far as because my whole life i heard
about the four food groups and you build
it around a protein
this is what this guy's saying um
he's basically saying oh i know i i this
is going to be [ __ ] hilarious because
i can't read
this is terrible basically saying
you know when you go to the supermarket
and they say that [ __ ] that that you
know they'll say like this butter is 98
fat free you know then you're like so
the spot is [ __ ] only two percent fat
kid
two percent um it's actually [ __ ]
butter is 100 fat
what they did is how they got around it
is they just if you took like
butter which is 100 fat and you threw it
in a glass of water and then you stirred
it up
and then rather than counting the
caloric value of it
of the butter which is still a hundred
percent fat
you did it by weight and you included
the glass and the [ __ ] water
that's how it becomes two percent fat by
weight it's then becomes two percent per
fat but the [ __ ]
butter is still 100 fat it's like two
percent milk
is really 49 fat
all right does that make any sense well
it shouldn't because i'm stupid so let
me read what this this [ __ ] guy wrote
and he's smart because he's an md using
weight instead of calories in nutrient
analysis
tables has evolved into a ploy
to hide how nutritional unsounded many
foods are
the role of the usda was originally to
promote the products
of the animal agricultural industry over
50 years ago the usda began promoting
the so-called four basic food groups
with meat and dairy products in the
number one and number two spots on the
list
financed by the and this was financed by
the meat and dairy industry
and backed by nutritional scientists on
the payroll
of meat and dairy of the meat and dairy
industry
this promotion ignored science am i
going to get sued for this
um this program i'm only i'm only
quoting the book people this program
could be more accurately labeled the
four food myths
it was taught in every classroom in
america to me included
with posters advocating a diet loaded
with animal protein
fat and cholesterol the results of this
fraudulent program were dramatic in more
than one more ways than one
americans began eating more and more
animal foods
the campaign sparked the beginning of
the fastest growing
cancer hang on i got to turn the page
epidemic in history and heart attack
rates soared to previously unheard
levels so i don't know whether you
believe that or not
i got to still think that people were
always eating steaks
all i know is i'm going to try to give
this thing a shot
it's not that i'm going to go vegan all
right
and i know if you try to do anything
outside the norm of that
automatically people are going to be
sending me emails first you try a prius
now you're a vegan why don't you just
stick a dick in your ass like it always
becomes that
right um no actually i'm gonna try to
have one salad a day at the very least
to offset my [ __ ] steak eating ways
you know i don't know the [ __ ] book
basically blew my mind if it's even
remotely true and i got to admit i've
kind of been doing it a little bit
and it's uh it's making me feel pretty
good and i'm [ __ ] like a [ __ ]
racehorse
sorry ladies um
i'm actually learning how to eat a salad
without any dressing on it because i
guess that even like olive oil has 150
calories
per teaspoon and i got to tell you i
easily put
seven teaspoons that's not even that
much
you know yeah but yeah you know i might
as well eat a [ __ ] burger
i'm an idiot so to eat a salad
without dressing i swear to god you
don't know the misery but what ends up
happening is you get used to it
and i swear to god the onions and the
tomatoes
maybe a carrot in there whatever the
[ __ ] you have and that becomes the
dressing
you actually get excited to eat a tomato
you know it's funny i don't think i sold
that as much as i made people
run to go eat more [ __ ] meat but
whatever i'm gonna try it out because um
because i hate working out i got to go
down and i got to go try and work off
1 8 of what the [ __ ] i did to my body at
the lsu game
god damn it i was upset after that game
what happened i actually did the dumbest
thing i could ever do i actually have
another [ __ ] team that i'm now gonna
live and die for
so what are the odds they're gonna win
the championship every year
zero so every [ __ ] year there's gonna
be some level of disappointment
you know well they won the citrus bowl i
guess that's kind of good
all right next one um here we go
gay son bill my son just left for
college this year
and when i was cleaning out his room i
found several notes from he and his best
friend from high school
these two were together all the time and
are rooming together right now in
colleges
colleges in college god i'm [ __ ]
pathetic the notes i found were from
from one another on special occasions
like christmas
all of them said essentially the same
thing i know nobody can
know but our love is real and we can
express ourselves better in college oh
jesus here we go here we go
they go on to talk about their nights
and hotels and how their girlfriends
never knew they were gay
my son talks about how he can never tell
me
because i he thinks i will disown him
oh my god are the hiccups coming back is
this story exciting me
um bill i don't know what to do
i haven't told anyone and i'm not mad at
him or anything and don't care that he
is gay
but i want to know if i should tell him
i know his secret
jesus why do you guys ask me these
questions like i'm qualified
i'm not qualified to answer this but
this is what i would do
first of all the fact that you know
you're not going to judge him and you
won't disown him
his biggest fear is is just that it's
only a fear so that's that's a good
thing so
i don't have any kids but i know that
that if my son had some giant fear
i would want to if i could in any way
alleviate
that stress from his life i would um
i would so i would just i would
i don't know i would sit down with him
and i would just say look
okay tell him you love him and all that
stuff so he chills
and say you know whatever you said you
know i was cleaning out your room i
found these notes
i mean i i don't know how this is you
almost want to ask you got to ask
somebody gay about this because i don't
know if this is going to be like
if it's up to him you don't want to
shock the kid
but uh i would think that i i would
think
and just say you're not going to disown
him you're not mad at him or whatever i
i i would think and i'm not qualified i
would think once he got over the shock
of holy [ __ ] my biggest fear in life my
dad found out
once he finds out you're not [ __ ] mad
you give him a hug and then just say
listen and i'm not gonna [ __ ] tell
anybody
you know it just hurt me it made me feel
sad that you that you were
thinking that i would be like that with
you i'm not you're my son i love you
that's that's it you know
and i would just do it like that and
then just say i'm not gonna say anything
about your friend
i'm not gonna say anything to your
mother
uh you know well that probably puts you
in a situation with
i don't [ __ ] know i don't know how to
go beyond that but that's that's what i
would do
all right once again i don't know what
the [ __ ] i'm doing
so there you go that's that's what i
would do okay good luck to you sir
okay moving on book recommendation
e to live live to fly sorry
um bill i hope all is well with you well
i hope all is well with you too sir
or ma'am hermaphrodite
um i just wanted to say that i enjoy
listening to your podcast early in the
morning while i practice guitar before
work
or even better while i'm wasting time on
my cubicle how do you practice guitar
listening to this [ __ ] um anyway i heard
you mentioned in the past that you're a
fan of body weight exercise yes i am
i'm not sure if you heard of ross
i can't read that word animate
e-n-a-m-a-i-t
but he is an x-boxer and physical
trainer who lives in massachusetts
he put uh he put a great book out called
never gymless
a few years back and i've been using it
on a daily basis to keep in shape
ross is a bare knuckle no [ __ ] kind
of guy i think you'll enjoy the book if
you're into using your own body weight
to keep in shape
i am in no way affiliated with ross well
i'll believe you because you just told
me you weren't
uh or anything like that i just want to
let you know that i enjoy your work and
thought you might be interested in this
book
yeah i'll check it out never gymless
that's oddly comforting the gym will
always be there
and those times when you can't work out
those were the times when i carried you
uh movie recommendation bill you got to
see wreck it ralph
it made me laugh and cry oh geez i
didn't laugh when i saw
cosby and i didn't cry when my relatives
died
oh you didn't laugh when you went to see
bill cosby and you didn't cry when your
relatives died but wreck it ralph
i think i saw some of that i think i saw
i think i saw something about that which
is that one there's one out there that
looks like a pixelated angry me
that's coming out uh
i don't know anyways overrated
underrated underrated being from a pro
sports town
and flying to new orleans and
experiencing
a college football game between two sec
rivals
i'm telling you put it on your bucket
list
all right go buy your wife some shoes
there you go sweetie these are for you
and these two tickets for me
go [ __ ] yourself i'll see you in three
days
and by the way if you get if you get
hiccups
and you want to cure them they got all
these different cures and all that the
biggest thing is
just don't eat like an [ __ ] and drink
like an [ __ ] like i did
oh by the way by the way this time
tomorrow we have the big election here
in the states
i don't know if you heard about it
people out there in sydney australia
melbourne melbourne is that how you say
it melbourne
perth oslo helsinki all these [ __ ]
places i go to now i don't know if you
guys heard about it i'm sure it's all
over you [ __ ]
it blows me away that you guys give a
[ __ ] considering i can't name any of
your guys other than tony blair
and the reason why i know tony blair is
he's got such a [ __ ] great show biz
name
ladies and gentlemen keep it going for
that [ __ ] tony blair
you know he almost needs a black dude to
bring him up that name so smooth
keep it going for tony blair
um anyways uh
so what do you think who are you calling
paul verzi is dying he he wants
he's romney all [ __ ] day he wants
romney
i don't wanna either i don't even know
who i'm gonna vote for this time
i don't even [ __ ] know i have no
[ __ ] clue
it i don't give a [ __ ] it's not it
doesn't matter
they're both gonna roughly do the same
[ __ ] thing
because the same people got money on
both [ __ ] guy
um i don't know i don't know what i'm
gonna do but uh
i don't know i've had it
i i just think people are so [ __ ]
stupid and that's coming from me who
can't even read out loud
44 years of age i just think people like
i just don't understand how they process
information
you know what i mean the way they they
they look at [ __ ] they never connect one
presidency to another it's like people
can't
like whatever's going on they're like oh
who's in office oh it's his
fault you know they don't keep seeing
like the same problems keep
getting [ __ ] worse and worse and
worse i just don't i just don't believe
that the president can [ __ ] do
anything all he can do
he's like mark sanchez he just has to
try and manage the game
don't throw a pick mark don't throw a
pick that's basically all he can do
you know other than that
how you gonna tell how you gonna turn
this country around like
corporations are so [ __ ] powerful
that they're beyond the borders of this
country
like you know what i thought was really
[ __ ] up in this literally treasonous
activity
is like all those people out there
dealing with uh
hurricane susan sally i i for some
reason i just cannot remember the
[ __ ] name of
that goddamn hurricane that [ __ ] where
everybody
is lining up to get gas and all of a
sudden gas becomes like
5.99 a gallon to do that to your fellow
countrymen
when they're involved in that type of
situation to raise the price of food to
do all that to make money off of
people's misery like that
i was kidding who that's page one of
capitalism but i i personally that
that's just that's treasonous
you should be if anything you should try
to be keeping the prices steady you
should be or
or try to drop them if you can
[ __ ] help people out
they're [ __ ] coming up to you with
their pockets inside out
two shoes that don't even [ __ ] match
and you're gonna try to get an extra
[ __ ] two dollars a gallon off of them
or whatever
i i just that that isn't right and a
[ __ ] right not my america
um
anyways that's the podcast for this week
i felt oddly comfortable doing this with
my headphones on
even though i couldn't hear myself you
know what it is if you put them on i can
still hear my voice in my head which
makes me feel good it's soothing to me
all right so here's the deal i got one
more road gig this year
i'm going to be at the university of
southern connecticut on november 17th
it is open to the public to get you and
i'm just saying that
i don't even know if that's true but i
think it's true considering people are
emailing me about it saying if i'm going
to tone it down by the for the love of
god
get some goddamn adults in that crowd
all right
um and then i think that's it then all
the rest of my gigs what do i got i got
breath that's
it all they got is breyer left and
another [ __ ] yeah
has gone by can you believe it
all right well that's the podcast for
this week as always people
um if you'd like to support this podcast
go to uh
emma go to billboard.com click on the
podcast page
then click on the link to amazon.com and
uh all you got to do
is go buy something you don't have to do
it if you want to and then
amazon doesn't cost you any extra money
amazon then just kicks me a little bit
of money
and i take a portion of the out and i
take a portion of any ad money that i
make on this
and i uh i send it to the wounded
warriors project so you'd be supporting
me
and supporting the troops and you know
what look what i just did there
i just did what all these corporations
are doing now
where they try and align themselves with
some sort of
you know some sort of cause that there's
no way you're not going to be against it
like that whole breast cancer thing
like you've seen the five hour energy
the little pink ones and every time you
buy a pink five hour energy
liquid cocaine we will give a portion
of the proceeds to finding a cure for
breast cancer now the key there is
a portion of the proceeds
what do you think that pro portion is i
heard with a certain credit card company
it was one penny for every charge
regardless of how big it was
[Laughter]
so if people are doing that [ __ ] can you
really get mad that they're raising
price of gas during the [ __ ] during
the [ __ ] hurricane
you know what i mean i'll tell you
wouldn't do something
like that ari shafir irish your fear
wouldn't
you ever go to his merch page you see
the quality that he has on that
i've been in this business long enough
to know how much having all those extra
colors in your t-shirt
or on the cover of your cd or dvd how
much that's going to cost you
and he says [ __ ] that i have an artistic
vision um
ari shafir would not raise gas prices
and because of that
you should go uh go you should go to all
things comedy and you should listen to
his podcast the septic tank
the skeptic tank septic i'm such a
[ __ ] idiot the skeptic tank and i'm
actually gonna uh try to get on uh
get on his show um that's it so that's
it people
if you didn't believe me the first time
i said it twice that is [ __ ] it
that's the podcast for this week go [ __ ]
yourselves thank you to everybody who
came out to the show
here at harrah's in new orleans this is
going to be a regular stop for me on the
tour
and i'm always going to be coming
through during football season next year
i'm going to try to do
uh lsu and go to a a hornets game
while i'm out here check that one off
the list but tonight saints eagles
and i'm going to laugh my ass off
watching um these polite southerners
i feel like southerners who knows you
know you always got to wonder if one of
them's in the clan
but whatever outwardly polite
fans dealing with dealing with these
[ __ ] eagles fans and what's funny is
i actually think the saints are going to
win
because every time i go to an athletic
event
and it's against a philly team even if i
was
for the philly team because i love the
flyers their fans are so
[ __ ] obnoxious by the end of it i'm
rooting for them to lose
um but they always end up winning
they've won every time i went to a
bruins flyers game with my mother
and they were sitting right behind me
four of them down low total [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and ah the hiccups are coming back dude
i literally i have a sore esophagus
a [ __ ] sore windpipe literally like
it was doing sit-ups
um can you take
bear for that all right
how awful is your job you're still
listening to this go [ __ ] yourselves
i'll talk to you next week that's it
that is it let me hit stop
okay [ __ ] you
you